welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition AKA christian fail
and this episode were breaking down some
massive new updates we have in regards
to the batman every week same bat-time
same bat-channel
we go over the movie and since the
reveal of the Batsuit last week we've
got a ton of information on the upcoming
films throughout this video we'll be
discussing the big bats in theory the
sheet that reveals when the Batmobile
could be seen some plot leaked details
and a lot more there may be some
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything about the film potentially
ruined then I highly suggest that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into a breakdown
of the Batman okay so the bat suit broke
the internet last week with a big video
posted by Matt Reeves that gave us our
first look at what the Dark Knight will
be donning in the movie since then
there's been a couple of things come out
as well as the theory that the bat
symbol itself would be made from the gun
that Joe Chill used to kill the Wayne's
Chill could definitely be in the film
due to the fact that it looks like the
crime was solved and this is how the
murder weapon was retrieved the theory
has been picking up a lot of steam and
it actually pulls directly from several
comic book arcs including Detective
Comics 1000 which was titled manufacture
for use in that Bruce retrieved the gun
used by Chill and melted it down
reforging it as a metal plate and then
he placed it under the bat symbol on his
chest so that it served as something
that would protect rather than cause
harm
it shows the psyche of Batman himself
who similar to the Joker could have went
over the deep end after one bad day but
instead he chose to be a force for good
the story was penned by Kevin Smith and
he even said that he hopes it's true but
it looks like it could well be as we
have a mock-up of a gun that appears to
confirm the theory with these
side-by-side you can see how everything
lines up and it appears that the chest
symbol is definitely going to be pulling
from this in addition to this we have an
insider who is currently working on the
film that says there is going to be a
second bat suit in the movie that is
revealed after a certain scene for weeks
now we have been saying that there's
gonna be a big moment in a Cathedral in
the film
this was initially one of the first
leaks after a huge soundstage was
revealed in Bedfordshire recently this
was given a lot more precedent by a
casting sheet that dropped giving a ton
of information not only does it mention
a party scene that will take place on
Halloween but it also confirms that a
funeral scene will be filming in between
the 16th and 20th of March Twitter user
Coddington sheds who is reportedly a big
airship fan said shed warned filming is
in full swing the place is filled with
American police SWAT teams and a load of
people dressed in funeral attire in
addition to this a person working on the
movie posted the following film chair
that shows Robert Pattinson seat and
shouts the little Vengeance that has
been written on this it looks like the
person has been on set and they also
dropped a pretty big pot leak that
discusses what will be happening had the
aforementioned funeral scene and how it
will end up leading to Batman needing a
second suit the information was posted
to the subreddit DC EU leaks and it says
the following we finished building a
huge Cathedral set in there just a bit
ago and have begun filming inside so
recently Matt Reeves revealed the
Batsuit we just started filming with it
recently it looks very cool in person
and Robert looks great what I know from
filming in the current Cathedral set
piece is that this suit gets destroyed
very early on I think it is due to a
villain but I couldn't tell it's
Batman's prototype suit and once it gets
destroyed he makes a new one I haven't
seen it in action but I saw a few
pictures taken by someone who was
putting it together it's extremely
similar to spider-man shield suit from
the far from home movie last year the
material is very similar being a sort of
tactical padded fabric material there's
way less straps and extra details on the
bat suit compared to the spider-man suit
but the material and look is very
similar it's gray with full black gloves
extending to his forearms and black
boots the symbol is no longer metal and
lacking years it's a more classic
version of the symbol on the first suit
in the film the cowl is made of a higher
quality material than the leather of the
first cowl the ears are medium to long
lengths and the mouth opening is much
smaller he no longer has a collar and I
think he might have the white eyes to
the utility belt is a bronze
Gold faded color and it's more pouch
than the futuristic metal type bell of
the Nolen films if I had to describe the
suit and pictures rather than words it
would be a cross of this in this and
they then dropped the following images
so that's really interesting and I think
it makes a lot of sense when the suit
was released a lot of people did say it
looks slightly like a cosplay version
and the description on this sounds more
in line with what some people were
hoping for personally I love the suit
reveal but I know from the comments in
the video that many were disappointed
with how it came across this turns out
to be true then I think that the white
eyes would please a lot of people but as
always take leaks like this with a pinch
of salt though it does line up with
certain casting calls and more there is
potential that it could be made up but
if it is true I'm very excited to see
the evolution of the costume I think we
can pretty much guarantee that the batsu
won't be the one that Batman uses for
the majority of his career so the change
ups do you make a lot of sense the user
has since deleted their post account and
probably been found and shot by Warner
Brothers as leaks like this are always a
big security risk when stuff like this
happens it tends to be true rather than
false so that does seem to give the post
some weight to it I'll keep an eye out
for any updates on the suit on the
subreddit because it's being given a lot
more authenticity recently due to some
of the leaks the current image on-screen
was posted a couple of weeks ago as a
Batman bat suit concept art post but I
didn't report on it because it did just
look like mock-up to me however as we
now know your boy death is the world's
worst detective and this is actually
very very similar to the suit that we
ended up getting in the recent reveal so
yeah I'll keep an eye out for more
things like that fool me once shame on
me fool me twice shame on shame on you
you know you you could anyway before we
get into the rest of the video I just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the Infinity Saga box set
to one random subscriber all you have to
do to be in with the chance of winning
is like the video subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
updates in the comment section below the
winners gonna be chosen at random on the
15th of March in this set will be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part okay so now the Batsuit has been
shown everyone's next question is when
will we see the Batmobile and villains
well if you've been keeping up to date
with the channel then you'll know that
we posted a report from British
newspaper The Daily Record that said
that the Batmobile would be seen on the
streets of Glasgow pretty soon we do
know that the film team are going to be
shooting on the streets of the skosh
City very soon as we have a full sheet
of the shooting schedule that outlines
the dates of when we could be seeing the
car not only does this list the streets
that filming is going to take place on
and if you're in Glasgow you should
definitely try and make the trip out
there but it also shows the times and
dates that they will happen the first
scene will be shot on the 21st of
February from 3:00 p.m. all the way up
until midnight and then more filming
will happen over the next three days
because of this it does seem very likely
that the Batmobile will be either shown
on the 21st or before then the 21st is a
Friday and as Reeves did drop the
Batsuit on a Thursday it is possible
that it will be shown officially on the
20th I'm sure many people working on the
film would rather have a full video or
professional photograph it's the first
thing that people see rather than a
leaked video taken on someone's phone we
don't know for definite but earlier in
the month we did hear leaks that the
suit would come out on the 14th and then
it pretty much dropped then so it does
make a lot of sense the catsuit is also
something that people are eagerly
anticipating and it hopefully won't be
too long before we get our first glimpse
at that twitter account the bat robber
regularly post news and reports on the
Batman and they dropped a tweet that
stated that they've heard from inside is
that the suit will look incredibly close
to the arkham knight design that we now
have on screen they said that it will be
black made of leather and have a helmet
though there was no mention of goggles
and this is not being reported by any
other outlet it was also said that
Catwoman would have leather boots
similar to the design that she Don's
from time to time in the comics so this
seems like it's keeping in line with the
source material we haven't heard any
rumors yet of when it will be posted but
hopefully it's not too long and finally
we have some more images that show the
leaked footage we reported on last week
in higher-quality you checked out the
prior video you'll know that we
broke down some leaked footage that
showed a jogger and Gotham being jumped
by a gang we now have some high-quality
photographs that show the gang info get
up we can see that the makeup is indeed
black and white and this does line up
with these thugs being part of the
penguin gang I had a couple of people
still argue that this would be part of
the Joker gang but these pictures show
the black and white paint in more detail
you will probably remember from Batman
Returns that the penguin also rolled
with a clown type of gang as he was from
a traveling circus and this could be why
the gang has smiles on again I don't
really think it's the Joker as black and
white tends to be you specifically with
the penguin but I guess we'll see in the
upcoming weeks anyway that's all of the
news on the Batman that we have this
week obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the Batman updates so
comment below and let me know make sure
you subscribe to the channel up of
videos like this every day and if you
want something else to watch we've got a
great breakdown of the Batsuit and the
other updates on the movie that you may
have missed which are going to be linked
at the end you want to support the
channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey
I'll click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you